Fred sent me a tape when the new when
the Rolling Stones come out with an
album Fred likes to uh go home and
record a song that he thinks is what
what the Rolling Stones are going to
record is that he sent it to me yeah so
he sent him I said I said what am I
going to do with this I think what it
was is this the first time they've
recorded an album in 18 years yes and
they're making a big deal about it they
went to the trouble of putting together
a video which the video was great by the
way it's uh it's got what's her name
Sydney Sweeney we're only around I've
seen it Mercedes but what was really
cool is like they had all the old
Billboards of old Rolling Stones albums
and covers and things like that they
kind of animate it make it come to life
it was really really well done no I
understand the Rolling Stones doing that
but your thing is to go home before the
record comes out and pretend well
it's not going to sound like kind of a
call back to the days many many moons
ago when Harlem Shuffle came out there
was like a song that the stones were
going to put out and we record at Harlem
Shuffle and put it out to just piss
everybody off and make the radio
stations think that we had an advanced
copy yeah but now nobody cares because
there's no you know in other words the
record company okay all right anyway uh
so Fred learned that the stones are
coming out with a song called
understanding and Fred made up a song as
the rolling stone song is angry all
right it says here fake rolling stone
song oh you're standing okay gotcha it's
not understanding no the rolling stone
song is is no I know this fake song is
understanding something we don't have
yes that's what I just said
[Music]
here's Fred pretending to be the wrong
stuff
very nice
gotta have a try